Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
« Tu me dis, j’oublie ;
tu m’enseignes, je me souviens ;
mais si tu m’impliques, j’apprends. »
Cette citation de Benjamin Franklin
nous rappelle une évidence,
celle que l’apprentissage passe d’abord
par la pratique, par le faire,
et qu’il est mieux de faire plutôt que
d’écouter ou de regarder quelqu’un
qui vous explique ou
qui vous montre quelque chose.
Cette supériorité de la pédagogie
dite active, du learning by doing,
ce n’est pas une croyance, c’est quelque
chose de scientifiquement démontré.
Ça marche pour les maths et les langues.
Mais ce qu’on sait,
c’est que ça marche particulièrement
quand il s’agit d’apprendre un métier,
une compétence professionnelle.
Ce qu’on sait aussi,
c’est que ça marche particulièrement bien
pour les personnes pas à l’aise
avec la pédagogie scolaire traditionnelle,
descendante, académique,
et que c’est complètement indiqué
pour les gens qui ont vraiment
besoin de compétences.
Je pense aux gens qui quittent le système
scolaire - plus de 100 000 par an -
aux personnes qui sont
en recherche d’emploi,
aux réfugiés qui ont besoin de compétences
pour s’insérer dans les sociétés
dans lesquelles ils arrivent.
Aux personnes en situation
de handicap aussi,
qui sont plus au chômage et moins
qualifiées que le reste de la population
parce que le système
n’est pas adapté à eux.
Mais je pense aussi à vous, à moi,
à tous les gens qui vont avoir besoin
de monter en compétence,
de se former tout au long de leur vie
car les métiers vont évoluer,
certains vont être créés,
certains vont disparaître.
La pédagogie active est
complètement indiquée pour ça.
Quand je vois cet amphi qui est très
impressionnant, chargé d’histoire,
je me dis qu’il n’a pas été conçu
dans une logique de pédagogie active.
C'est le moins qu'on puisse dire.
Normal, on n’y apprend pas à développer
des compétences professionnelles,
on n'apprend pas des métiers, on apprend
des connaissances, on apprend des savoirs.
En revanche, la configuration spatiale
ne permet pas vraiment les interactions.
Vous pouvez me l'accorder.
Et quand le confinement est arrivé,
certainement que des gens ici
se sont dit :
« Chouette, on va quitter
l’amphi Richelieu.
On va se retrouver sur Zoom,
ça va être trop bien. »
Je pense qu’ils ont
assez rapidement déchanté.
Après les premiers temps pour pouvoir
faire quelques cours dans son lit
ou sur son canapé,
assez vite, les interactions ont manqué.
Pourquoi ? Parce que la pédagogie
n’a pas évolué, même avec Zoom.
Et parce qu’il manquait quelque chose
d’incroyable qui est dans cette salle,
c'est l'interaction humaine
en direct, en live.
Ce que je me dis aussi
en pensant à ce confinement,
c’est que ce que nous proposent les MOOCs,
ces cours massivement
distribués sur Internet,
ce n’est pas très loin de ce distanciel,
mais c’est moins bien.
Moins bien
parce qu’il n’y a pas d’interaction.
Moins bien car au moins en Zoom,
on a le prof en live,
et car, quand on regarde
des vidéos pré-enregistrées,
on ne peut pas interagir
avec d’autres personnes -
on ne sait pas qui le fait
en même temps que nous,
puisqu’on peut regarder
les vidéos quand on veut.
Ceci étant, le distanciel,
le digital, les MOOCs,
on nous présente souvent ça
comme des solutions très innovantes,
des solutions très démocratiques qui vont
permettre de toucher plus de personnes.
Personnellement,
je n’en suis pas convaincu.
Formation professionnelle,
apprendre un métier,
développer des compétences,
souvent, on associe ça
à des choses assez ringardes.
On pense à des filières techniques
ou professionnelles.
On pense à des salles de formation
ou des salles au sous-sol d’hôtels.
On fait de la formation avec, vous savez,
le bloc-notes, le petit crayon,
les chouquettes,
la feuille d’émargement pour le matin,
pour l’après-midi.
Et puis un formateur, un bon repas.
Ça paraît ringard, mais pédagogiquement,
ça peut être extrêmement riche,
et ça reste extrêmement riche.
A contrario,
je suis sûr que vous avez à l’esprit
des métiers qui paraissent plus sexy
et des formes de modalités pédagogiques
qui vous paraissent très, très cool,
mais qui ne le sont pas forcément et qui
sont peut-être toxiques pédagogiquement.
Je vais vous prendre trois exemples
un peu provocateurs.
Comment devenir Jedi dans
Star Wars avec Yoda ?
Comment devenir chanteur à la télé
avec The Voice ?
Ou la Star ac’ - pour les plus anciens.
Et comment devenir sorcier avec
Poudlard dans Harry Potter ?
Ces trois exemples
ont l’air assez disruptifs,
mais les modèles pédagogiques derrière
sont très ringards, voire très toxiques,
car il s’agit de sélection
drastique à l’entrée -
beaucoup de candidats, assez peu d’élus.
On va dire que la pédagogie est
assez descendante, assez rigide.
Les professeurs sont certes
des professionnels,
mais ils ont leur carrière derrière eux.
Et surtout, c’est basé sur la compétition,
sur la performance individuelle,
sur les notes, sur les sanctions,
voire sur les exclusions.
Avouez que ce n’est pas forcément
un modèle qui fait rêver
quand on y réfléchit un peu.
Pourtant, une autre formation
professionnelle est possible.
La formation professionnelle de demain,
celle dont je rêve,
elle existe déjà.
Elle est déjà parmi nous
et elle a même toujours existé.
Cette formation professionnelle, elle a
toujours été basée sur des principes clés.
Le premier principe, j’en ai parlé
au début, c’est la pédagogie active.
J’ai cité Benjamin Franklin,
mais j’aurais pu citer Aristote qui,
bien avant lui, il disait :
« Ce que nous devons apprendre,
nous l’apprenons en faisant. »
Ça paraît simple, ça paraît limpide.
Une métaphore que j’utilise beaucoup
pour décrire la pédagogie active,
c’est celle du simulateur de vol.
On ne va pas envoyer un pilote tout
de suite dans un appareil dans le ciel.
On va simuler un environnement qui
ressemble comme deux gouttes d’eau
à ce qu’il va connaître une fois
qu’il sera en situation de travail.
Cette mimétique est très importante.
Quand on forme quelqu’un
à devenir un professionnel,
ce sont des professionnels
qui doivent le former -
ils transmettent leur savoir -
pas des formateurs de métier.
Il faut connaître le métier
pour le transmettre.
La deuxième caractéristique,
c’est qu’il faut que cette formation
professionnelle révolutionnaire de demain,
elle soit synchrone, elle soit en direct,
elle soit en live.
Elle ne peut pas être en différé.
Les apprenants doivent interagir
avec le formateur, avec le professeur.
Ils doivent interagir entre eux.
Cette formation a besoin
d’être collective.
On ne peut pas rester devant
un écran à regarder des vidéos.
Ce n’est pas comme ça
qu’on monte en compétence.
Le dernier point,
qui est peut-être le plus important :
cette formation professionnelle
de l’avenir -
qui a toujours existé, je le rappelle -
elle doit être gratuite
et elle doit rester gratuite.
En France, on a la chance
d’avoir un système éducatif,
d’avoir Pôle emploi, les régions, l’État,
pour se former professionnellement,
gratuitement la plupart du temps.
Mais il y a beaucoup de configurations
où les formations deviennent payantes
et dès qu’on sort de France,
la plupart des systèmes éducatifs et
de formation professionnelle sont payants.
Et parfois, même en payant,
on n’a pas accès à la pédagogie active,
dont je voulais vous parler.
William Gibson, un auteur de
science-fiction que j’aime beaucoup,
génial et visionnaire,
qui parlait du cyberespace
avant que le Web soit inventé,
disait que le futur, il est déjà là,
il est juste pas réparti équitablement.
On n'y a pas tous accès.
Je crois que la formation professionnelle,
la pédagogie dont je vous parle,
c’est exactement la même chose :
elle n’est pas distribuée équitablement.
Pourquoi ce n’est pas cette pédagogie-là
qui règne partout ?
Tout simplement parce qu’elle
est complexe, parce qu’elle est exigeante,
qu’elle demande des formateurs
là à plein temps,
toujours en interaction.
Donc, forcément, elle est plus chère,
elle est plus compliquée à massifier
et elle est forcément
beaucoup moins rentable.
Mais cette formation professionnelle,
cette pédagogie,
vous la trouvez partout en France,
pas loin de chez vous,
pour tous les métiers,
dans des centres comme l’Afpa, le Greta,
les CFA, l’enseignement technique,
les écoles de production.
Tous ces organismes utilisent
la pédagogie active
et ça donne des résultats
individuels et collectifs prodigieux.
Dans le numérique aussi,
ça existe bien entendu.
C’est cette pédagogie-là
qu’on utilise à Simplon.
La puissance de cette pédagogie
nous a permis d’amener à l’emploi
15 000 personnes depuis 2013,
dont la plupart sont sans qualification,
n’avaient jamais fait de numérique avant.
Maintenant, ils sont professionnels
du numérique
dans des métiers de développeur,
de data, d’IA.
C’est prodigieux.
La puissance de cette pédagogie,
elle permet de s’affranchir de tout,
des âges, des niveaux
de qualification, des genres.
On a 43% de femmes dans nos formations
malgré un syndrome de l’imposteur
et un milieu d’un machisme
incroyable dans le numérique.
Par le faire, par cette pédagogie,
on a réussi à s’affranchir de tout.
Et pourtant, si un jour vous rentrez
dans un centre de formation Simplon,
vous ne serez pas forcément impressionné,
il n’y a pas d’IA, ni de digital partout,
il y a des tables, des chaises,
des gens qui interagissent.
Ce qui surprend,
c’est qu’on n’arrive pas
à distinguer les professeurs des élèves.
C’est un joyeux bazar
où tout le monde échange
et tout le monde monte
en compétence ensemble.
Et les résultats sont prodigieux.
Ce que j’ai envie de vous dire, c’est
que cette formation professionnelle-là,
celle de mes rêves, celle dont
on doit rêver pour nos enfants,
elle existent déjà,
mais il faut la préserver,
il faut la déployer,
il faut faire en sorte
qu’elle reste gratuite.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’elle est plus efficace,
elle est beaucoup plus inclusive
que toutes les autres pédagogies
et surtout parce que c’est ça,
l’innovation en pédagogie.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)